the texas gop has formally declared joe
biden to have been illegitimately
elected and while the media is running
on and on about voter fraud the actual
issue here has to do with
unconstitutional changes to voter laws
from the perspective of texas now i
don't want to get into just in the intro
the whole election debate but i want to
point out what the texas gop is saying
is yes they have issues with fraud
personally i don't agree with those
narratives however they also go on to
say that they are challenging the
constitutionality of voter rule changes
this lawsuit from texas it's texas v
pennsylvania went to the supreme court
who rejected to hear it
and if you don't listen you're not
changing the mind of anybody so now
we're ending up in this
i don't know constitutional crisis is
the direction we're going in because the
texas gop is voting on these things and
their
their confidence is shattered i don't
know what that's going to mean for the
rest of the country but
it also means that texas could vote to
secede in 2023 that's another big story
that's happening so we'll talk about all
of that we'll break down why people are
feeling this way
and i want to show you the texas v
pennsylvania lawsuit i covered it quite
a bit back in 2020 when the lawsuit
happened and interestingly following
that lawsuit a court in pennsylvania did
rule their universal mail in voting to
be unconstitutional so maybe youtube
doesn't want to hear that but that's a
fact let's talk about all that we also
have lithuania blocking russia from
transporting important materials into
the oblast of kaliningrad which russia
says is illegal and lithuania being a
nato state could drag nato into war with
russia so um i don't know what with a
civil war and world war three all all at
the same time let's go that'll be fun oh
oh oh also there's major food shortages
coming cool yeah exciting it's gonna be
great yeah because it's not just about
the fact that inflation is really high
it's also that while the costs are going
up the amount you're getting for the
same cost is going down so the inflation
is actually way higher than they're
really saying probably protect joe biden
or because they're not tracking
accurately and then you have all of
these different countries that get a
tremendous amount of their food imports
from ukraine and russia which they
aren't anymore and when they run out of
food they're gonna you know it's a world
war iii and hey how you guys doing
joining us to talk about all this is
angela mcardle thanks for having me who
are you i am the chair of the
libertarian national committee or more
colloquially known as the libertarian
party
very nice thank you for joining us you
guys recently had a big victory the
mises caucus like took over everything
that's right i am a former board member
of the mises caucus i had to resign
effective immediately once i was elected
to the national position but we did we
swept
the convention every single one of our
candidates for the national committee
and the judicial committee was elected
every single one wow all right we'll
we'll get into all that stuff as well
and we also have mary morgan oh hi
everyone barry
i'm the co-host of pop culture crisis
and before that i'm professional edge
lord
so i'll try to behave myself this is my
first time so go easy on me okay
now they're gonna get twice no yeah
they're gonna be alive damn it yeah it's
heating up
hey this weekend we harvested wheat out
of the front yard i don't know if you
guys knew this we actually blended tim
blended it up into powder flour i milled
it milled it in the blender and then we
uh and then we made bread out of it it
wasn't half bad no it actually it was a
bit moist and cakey that's because the
way it was stored uh didn't have a bread
box so i kept it in sealed and then the
moisture will make it
soggy i liked it though yeah me too i'm
glad you brought up constitutional
crisis earlier tim because i think this
is a sort of constitutional crisis what
we're facing with the way things have
been going the last three or four years
really since donald trump that election
and hillary's email all that stuff
but i think we need one because uh the
federal reserve in this international
banking system has been sapping the
united states for a hundred years and
it's it's make or break time i like it
yeah
well you guys wanted a libertarian and
you wanted a catholic and i brought you
one of each they're just not the ones
you were expecting i'm very excited to
talk to angela and mary tonight i love
being on with mary on pop culture crisis
we always have a great time excited to
hear a chance to say before we get
started my friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and download
virtual shield sign up 50 off lifetime
discount for a virtual private network
service this keeps you safe as you are
browsing the internet to a certain
degree it protects you from hackers
governments corporations they're trying
to spy on you take your data sell your
data and they want to know what you're
doing a virtual private network service
is a basic layer of security for you as
you browse the web and if you go to
surfing internet safe you will get
virtual shields vpn service which is
compatible with all devices it allows
you to browse the web safely securely
securely and anonymously using their
global network of servers and private
ips it lets you browse the web
anonymously so big name isps and other
third parties will not be able to
monitor and sell your activity when
using their vpn service your traffic is
routed through their secured encrypted
servers that means any restrictions
censorship or blocks on your internet
are bypassed
vpn plus is an additional suite of
services that expand your protection and
offer an enhanced level of service that
includes ad blocking malware blocking
unrestricted streaming protection plus
monthly maintenance and priority phone
support
60 days risk free available on all major
platforms windows mac ios and android
and it does all the work for you you
just got to download it and click go and
you're ready to go virtual shield routes
your internet through advanced encrypted
servers across the globe to prevent your
isp from being able to track your
internet traffic there are personal
family and business plans available and
it will also completely encrypt your
wifi connection blocking hackers and
everyone else from accessing your data
so again head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com thank you
virtual shield for sponsoring the show
and also go to timcast.com become a
member and help support our work
directly as a member you'll get access
to exclusive segments from this show the
not family-friendly version where we
swear a lot it's very it's very much
uncensored that's up at timcast.com
monday through thursday at 11pm you're
also supporting our other shows and our
journalists we have a bunch of
journalists we've hired a couple more
we're going to be adding more we're
doing that fact checking so with your
support we will continue that mission so
again go to timcast.com sign up and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
right now with your friends let's read
this first story from time
go no audio
when uh when we when we pull up the
display the audio is removed for some
reason oh interesting if you missed that
tim was talking about how awesome i was
for like two times for like five minutes
there you missed you want to let's do
this again that was pretty high let's
just use a different use this one yeah
here you go perfect all right let's
start over oh how sad i love that scene
okay
okay texas republicans declare biden
illegitimately elected reject 2020
election certification they say a
component of the 2022 platform adopted
by texas republicans on june 18th
rejects the outcome of the 2020 u.s
presidential election calling it a
constitutional violation we all know how
much youtube loves this story quote
the texas gop said we believe the 2020
election violated article 1 and 2 of the
u.s constitution that various
secretaries of state illegally
circumvented their state legislatures in
conducting their elections in multiple
ways including by allowing ballots to be
received after november 3rd 2020. the
resolution reads they go on to say they
believe that substantial election fraud
in key metropolitan areas significantly
affected results in five key states in
favor of joseph robinette biden jr now i
don't care for that last statement to be
completely honest i uh i i just i don't
care for it i think that a lot of really
angry people voted against trump and i
think it's kind of a cop-out now i know
a lot of people really you know believe
in the fraud narrative i think the
bigger issue is we know for a fact that
in several states they did change the
rules there were legal challenges they
were never ruled on the merits many of
them
pennsylvania is the perfect example and
this is what uh i want to highlight in
this story right away texas v
pennsylvania was 2020 texas said exactly
what they're saying now that various
states violated the constitution and the
way they handled the voting the supreme
court said we won't hear it
okay if someone comes to you and says i
believe this thing happened and you go
don't care i'm not listening they're
gonna say okay well it's not like my
mind was changed if if the supreme court
took the case heard the arguments maybe
now we would have some resolution so if
you've got a bone to pick take it up
with roberts and the rest of the supreme
court alito and thomas were the only
ones willing to hear it the reason why i
don't care for the fraud narrative for
one i'm not completely convinced i'm
sorry i just i'm just not i think a lot
of people were very much excited to vote
against donald trump and more
importantly
it's it's it's demoralizing and it is um
it's it's voter suppression in a sense
you're basically telling people to give
up but i'll tell you this
if there is a question about the
constitutionality or the rules in an
election that's something that should be
investigated it should be litigated so
that that way there is confidence in the
election
my i think what's most important here is
not necessarily the argument about 2020
because we're going on two years later
you know for the most part i think the
issue is
they never resolved the issue yeah that
republicans have and because of that
we're now moving into a midterm where
already we had one county otero county
refusing to certify the results and now
we're moving into 2024
it's going to be even crazier you think
texas is going to is going to be willing
to play with these other states when
they were like you wouldn't even listen
to our arguments in the first place our
mind has not been changed and now
they're building a platform based on
that that
that belief
how do you think conservatives are going
to be viewing the supreme court going
forward because historically people have
been really excited about the supreme
court we treat them we treat those
justices like their gods like they're
like they're more human they're better
than us human beings they're infallible
they can't do anything wrong do you
think that's going to change as a result
of this the supreme court is viewed that
way yeah i think a lot of people view
the supreme court as though they're
they're otherworldly beings and they're
infallible do you know what's the what's
the salary of a supreme court just isn't
it like 180 it's not that much it's not
very high yeah right
so you know i bring that up because yeah
a lot of people view the supreme court
as just like this you know all
powerful entity and i'm like some dude
just tried to kill kavanaugh and there's
like nothing he can do about it they're
protesting in front of his house and
there's nothing he can do about it and
he only makes 180k per year that is not
a lot of money to be dealing with this
level of threat through these threats
and violence yeah and they have no
enforcement authority
the the supreme court can come and be
like we want this and everyone go no and
they go but you have to
looks like they make 280 000. i'm sorry
280 chief justices not 180.
still yeah
every year they get a raise it looks
like 280's a lot of money
but like to be one of the most famous
and hated people that's the problem fame
and money they don't always scale
together and if you're super famous and
dirt poor you can't hire security you
can't afford it that's a big problem
there's also apparently bad fame when
people want to murder you that's not a
good thing that's pretty horrible
political fame is not necessarily
positive
yeah no that's why you you'd be better
off hosting like you know look at this
politico political show we'd be better
off we were just talking about like
johnny depp and amber heard and doing
pop culture stuff i think that you're
jealous
all right a little bit to be honest
i think the supreme court's got way too
much power man i think that there should
not be seven eight nine ten people
deciding the fates of the entire nation
it's insane yeah that's completely
insane to me how about supreme court
precedent
like
meaning what exactly i mean what do you
think about the fact that they can
decide something and then that's just
the law i think it's absolutely
ridiculous that you would give eight
people that power 12 people it's like it
is legislation
it's not finally it's not viewed as
legislation but we treat it as
legislation well
i mean i i think there are issues
the conversation to be had about you
know supreme court for sure and
authority but it is the interpretation
of the law as the legislation has passed
it right so
i think the founding fathers did a
really really great job trying to craft
you know government i think it's the
best we've seen so far certainly i think
we could probably do better you know the
idea that this is the end all be all of
good government it's not the case but
more importantly i think you know
probably early on it was way better than
it is now yeah absolutely i think it's
probably corrupted over a long period of
time well it's scaled up dramatically
social media has changed a lot
of the way people interact with just
political leaders in general like that
they can get a tweet they can get a
hundred thousand tweets messages a day
like back in the day 100 years ago they
were live on their farm and that's where
they were and no one really knew where
they lived or well so i i was reading
about the john brown raids and bleeding
kansas
and it's like 10 years or it's like six
years before the civil war
and i was i was reading about the raid
on harper's ferry yeah dude walked into
harper's ferry and took over like that
there was no communication so when they
walk in with a bunch of dudes with guns
they're like okay you're in charge now
the only reason they ended up getting
caught was because there was a train
they had stopped and then john brown let
the train leave they made it to i think
baltimore and then immediately got on
the telegraph and was like yo a bunch of
abolitionists took over the city and
they're doing like a slave revolt killed
a lot of people
yeah i think it was five people
five people died i could be wrong john
brown's hardcore but bleeding kansas was
nuts that was that so that was like
warfare that was just outright war or
civil was a state civil war
so uh but anyway i was reading about
this and i'm thinking like if anything
like that happened today the moment
someone banged down the door the text
the tweet would be out and everyone in
the world would know what was happening
the air force would be scrambled the air
force is already up there waiting they'd
just be like two hours out or less oh
they know before they're watching on
your phone and your gps as you're go
going to harpers ferry so like if john
brown existed today they'd be like hey
we noticed those five guys we've been
spying on are all in the same place and
they're heading towards this armory send
in the troops watch list yup boom done
done
so anyway i i bring that up because i'm
thinking about today and i'm thinking
about how social media has changed
everything
that the the amount of time it took for
the civil war to happen
it wouldn't be the same today today it
would be like
it's at the moment it kicks off everyone
knows it kicked off mm-hmm a bunch of
triggers
would happen like their power would get
shut down here then the power will get
shut down here then you see an explosion
while three places stall so are people
really
people are talking about secession or
balkanization which is the nicer way to
put it
how many people do you think are
seriously talking about open civil war
not many no i i think
bro i it was trending today on twitter
102 000 tweets on twitter but in the
morning i don't think they're actually
talking about real civil war they don't
know what that means that doesn't mean
that the reality doesn't matter hide in
a hole and hope that you don't get a
bomb dropped on you every day you're
right but that doesn't matter like
they're using the people people think
suppressors go pew pew pew because they
watched a movie yeah they they read a
book about civil war and i think they
know what it is they the these antifa
people i mean look at what happened with
aaron danielson in seattle took two to
the chest some grand just
people understand civil war is gonna be
you're gonna get groceries and then all
of a sudden an ied blows up next to you
and you're just a random person who has
nothing to do with this that's the kind
of reality of these conflicts that's the
reality of this conflict you had those
antifa people in portland walking around
with rifles and they pointed the gun at
the guy in the truck and said you know
stop and the guy gets out with his gun
you're going to be living in your house
and some and all of a sudden one day
people are going to walk up and be
shooting at each other and bolts are
gonna go flying it would be like they're
blowing up the freeways all the freeways
would be dis dissolved they would be
gone in a civil war and then the chinese
would invade the ccp would invade okay
well at some point the national guard or
the american military is going to come
into that equation so i guess it's just
we wonder when because we saw in
portland
well in portland it certainly wasn't
civil war but
didn't it look like it just on a small
scale
yeah civil strife i i suppose so
and i anticipate that if anything like
that happens it's going to start off
with civil strife it's not going to pop
off
with someone in a militia declaring
civil war
so i'll
i think when you bring up the national
guard there's like a like i suppose a
more worrying reality of
whichever faction is in control yeah is
holding the conch shell essentially is
wielding the power of of law enforcement
and military
so
donald trump was unwilling to send tom
cotton said sending the troops trump was
unwilling to do it and he's the
conservative one and right now you can
see the feds going to a garage to
investigate a poll rope you can see the
feds
ag unwilling to to go after the
protesters illegally protesting in front
of the homes of supreme court justices
so it very much looks like uh the
reality is
the democrats are willing to use the
power the conservative the republicans
are not and that means if there ever
wasn't an active conflict then those who
are in law enforcement who are just
going to follow orders are going to be
following wars of democrats so
they'll be they'll be involved i'll put
it this way
so we saw in uh a lot of news about
taylor lorenz you know taylor lorenz oh
yeah do you know taylor lorenz mary no
of her her number so she recently got
demoted um because she publishes fake
news about a couple youtubers
now not every people aren't really
they're not calling it a demotion
they're saying she was moved from the
features team to the to the tech team
but now she's being called a tech
reporter
so if you're writing feature opinion
columns and now you're just reporting on
tech that's a demotion sure but um you
know she gets featured on msnbc
because of mean tweets
yeah we've been swatted eight times
we've had a crut we've had the bomb
squad shut up we've had credible threats
and my private properties unaffiliated
with this show with tenants in them have
also been swatted
and you know it look i'll i'll say it i
guess it's kind of weird talking about
myself in this way as if i'm deserving
of attention or whatever
but some people a lot of people pointed
out hey like when one of the biggest
political shows is getting this much
threats and swatting and bomb threats
and stuff isn't that a big news story
but for some reason we don't crack the
news at all and i'm like this is exactly
what you should understand
when people threaten us with death when
we have to evacuate our studio for three
hours over a credible threat it is not
newsworthy to the establishment
when one reporter for the mainstream
media gets mean tweets and cries they
bring her on tv and they parade her
around
because we are
not a part of the establishment
so
i think it might have to do with her
just being a woman and women's
grievances maybe a little bit being seen
is more important but i think
look cnn got bomb threats
and they evacuated and it was like the
biggest news everywhere i mean even fox
news doesn't cover what's happening here
we we we don't matter to that world
right even though we we we rival the the
the viewership in terms of the key
demographic for many of these cable
shows in fact we beat cnn and key demo
viewership in prime time
so when i when i look at something like
that
when i look at the crimes committed
against us it's not just the media
ignoring it it's the question of people
who are posting this how is it that tim
cass has been swatted eight times
received two credible threats and has
had you know that's just here we've also
had other properties swatted that people
don't know about
they're like why haven't the feds caught
these people and i'm like it's a good
question isn't it
it's a real good question i mean why why
haven't they arrested the protesters
that are going to kavanaugh's or coney
barrett's house right well the better
question is why don't they care
right and i don't i don't think that
they care and i think that it's it's a
little bit related to this news story
with the texas republicans declaring the
election illegitimate and we may not
agree with why they're doing it
but i'm a little bit sympathetic to
their to their angst because they feel
like everything that they care about
everything that matters to them does not
matter to the people in charge exactly
this is a and this is exactly what was
uh happening prior to the first civil
war southern states not a fan of them
but they were saying why isn't the law
being upheld as we agreed to it
why was the north allowed to ignore the
law and the south wasn't right so they
said later
i don't know what's going to happen man
but i know reading about john brown is
really fascinating stuff it is dude this
look
it's it's crazy because
he was an abolitionist and and he would
often talk about this the declaration of
independence all men are created equal
the golden rule and all these things i
completely agree with but he was also
he walked up to walked into a dude and
shot him in the face
and and a lot of people called him a
madman they said he was insane he was a
psychopath
you gotta you gotta imagine what would
happen right now if some dude like
making the same statements as john brown
committed one of these acts the funny
thing is the left that props him up as a
hero would denounce him immediately yeah
because he was about freedom liberty and
yeah the declaration of independence
you got to change the language on that
one you have to yeah
they couldn't support that
but but yeah basically
texas filed a lawsuit let me pull it up
actually
texas filed a lawsuit texas v
pennsylvania in 2020
filed by the state texas attorney
general ken paxton uh blah blah blah
they said they alleged that georgia
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin violated
the u.s constitution by changing
election procedures through
non-legislative means the supreme court
said screw off
not a good way to go so what happens
if you say
i believe this was unconstitutional and
instead of actually getting that sit
down and that adjudication you're told
go away we won't hear what you have to
say
texas then goes and says okay
we've our mind has never been changed we
we continue to believe these things
and
you know what really frustrates me is
the cowardice
of the supreme court uh and and the
media
because they were too stupid and
cowardly to realize
there are more elections coming
and if texas says we believe it's
unconstitutional and only say we don't
care then they're going to say okay then
what happens come 2022. in the midterms
they're going to be like we don't we
don't we don't believe any of this is
legitimate which is literally what
they're doing what happens if in 2024
biden actually wins again i don't see it
as being possible to be honest but let's
say he doesn't run let's say some
democrat eric adams or gavin newsom runs
and then
wins and texas just goes don't know
don't care and this time they don't
certify the election so it could go two
different ways and i think there's a
little bit of a scale as to how that
could play out right they literally just
go and do their own thing they just
start ignoring the federal government
probably still sending in taxes taking
tax revenue in
that but but everything else they're
just not acknowledging it
and the other thing that could happen is
that things could get violent or they
could get incredibly violent
and i think a lot of that is going to
depend in large part on the response of
the federal government
and how violent they want to get with
people who are trying to
basically peacefully secede and i say
peacefully succeed i haven't seen it yet
so that's you know that's got a little
asterisk by it because we'll we'll see
whether or not it's peaceful the first
civil war was peaceful for two months
three months right and that's that's the
issue people think that
peaceful divorce is possible but i don't
think it is
why do you think it's not peaceful or
what possible so
the first civil war you had i think
seven states that could be wrong it was
they they seceded they made a
declaration declaration and that was it
for several months nothing happened
abraham lincoln then gets inaugurated
and says nope those military bases are
ours there you go
so what happens is
you've got federal authorities federal
law enforcement officers and if a state
secedes and then tells the fbi the cia
dhs get out and they say no
it can't be peaceful
that's going to be a real problem
that's that's the issue and you know
it's what's what's fascinating is what
ulysses says grant wrote about it he
said that every state has a right to to
succeed right it just means that you
will go to war
and if you lose you will live under the
rules of your of your your batters or
whatever you said your your captors or
whatever
so his idea was
you know you look at the american
revolution you have a right to say i
have a right to autonomy and and to
secede and you can try if you lose you
now live under the rules of those who
have defeated you
and then he his argument was
the union spent uh sacrificed blood and
treasure to admit these states into the
union
and there was a debt owed to the union
that if they were to leave it would be
like them giving being given free stuff
and then ripping them off and so that's
why they went to war see this is part of
my problem with government is not
everybody signed to that contract no not
everybody agreed plenty of people were
born after the fact plenty of people
didn't have especially in that age they
don't have social media they're not
reading up they don't know they're just
they come into this world they're just
trying to survive and prosper with their
families
maybe maybe one good hope for us
with any coming civil war would be that
it would be a very slow withdrawal and
slow pull out i think it would be ten
times faster could be because of because
of the internet and social the
information age yeah it's crazy to me
that um
man i mentioned this in a couple
segments earlier i was watching avengers
infinity war which was uh i think 2018
right 2018. yeah you should know that
and uh well you're the pop culture
person
but but i was thinking about like what i
was doing when this movie came out
and i was like
do we not realize how much the water's
become has started to boil in the past
four years yeah
so i was thinking about how people kept
telling me since 2018 there was never
going to be a civil war and i was crazy
even today people tell me there's not
going to be a civil war and then when i
saw the story about texas and pulled up
texas v pennsylvania i was reading this
lawsuit i was like
this is this is how frogs boil in a pot
you can look at texas v pennsylvania and
see that you had i think 22 states
versus 22 states suing each other over
whether or not the election was
constitutional you had members of
congress refusing to certify you had
state legislatures sending alternate
electors and then you had january 6 and
there are still people acting like
nothing's happening
and i'm just like well
i don't think that there's going to be a
civil war i don't think it's even
possible i think because any war that we
get entangled in is global at this point
and it's not going to be on american
soil it's going to be all over the world
including on american soil but
something is definitely happening i just
don't think it's leading to i take the
authoritarian bet like abe lincoln that
we cannot
shovel this union this union is secure
the only reason we're able to have this
conversation is because of this union if
the union shatters we're all doomed
essentially like you think nuclear war
is a problem well
you count your blessings that you
haven't watched in newt go off
what do you think do you think there are
any parallels that can be drawn between
what we're seeing right now with the
encroaching totalitarianism and the
collapse of the soviet union
because that thing fell apart yeah and
people didn't have to go out and fight
and have streets filled with blood yeah
it was that the oligarchs wanted to
seize control i think that's big part of
why the soviet union fell was like
orchestrated by the oligarchy in russia
to seize power i didn't see that
happening here it seems they seem to
want to but it's foreign oligarchs that
are trying to do it i think the
difference is though with the soviet
union you had different countries you
had people who spoke different languages
you had people who were outright
effectively captured in the past few
decades the soviet union lasted what was
it 69 years yeah so you effectively have
russia just annexing other countries and
so what happens when you have country
imagine if texas
only spoke french and you know alabama
only spoke spanish well then i can
understand a collapse because there's
already a language barrier although the
closer you get to the border the more
people speak each other's language this
is the united states we've been it's 250
years 250 plus years so this is
everybody speaks english we have a lot
of shared history a lot of shared values
now it's starting to be ripped apart by
these two different factions you have
the constitutional republic which is
people who are american and then you
have the multicultural democracy and i
suppose alex jones would call it the
nationalists and the globalist is one
way
yeah yeah the bank for international
settlements the bankers the swiss
bankers the world economic forums
involved blackrock trying to buy
american land out from what's actually
blackstone is buying a lot of land and
blackrock will tell you that that's
conspiracy it's black rock because it's
black stone even though they were kind
of spin-offs of each other or one spun
off from the other we pulled this story
right here here we go from newsweek
texas could vote to secede from the u.s
in 2023 as gop pushes for referendum
the texas republicans are pushing for a
referendum to decide whether the state
should secede from the u.s the demand
for texans to be allowed to vote on the
issue in 2023 was one of many measures
adopted in texas gop's party platform
following last week's state convention
in houston now i want to point out it's
not the first time someone's called for
this but it seems to be moving forward
under a section titled state sovereignty
the platform states pursuant to article
1 section 1 of the texas constitution
the federal government has impaired our
right to local self-government therefore
federally mandated legislation that
infringes upon the 10th amendment rights
of texas should be ignored opposed
refused and nullified
texas retains the right to secede from
the u.s and the texas legislature should
be called upon to pass a referendum
consistent there too
now let me ask you
with all of these
libertarian types moving to texas yep do
you think there's going to be increasing
support for texas secession oh
absolutely the national libertarian
party just passed a platform change in
support of secession and the florida
state libertarian party did earlier this
year we're we're all about it because we
think that people should be able to live
their own lives and just peacefully
separate
we emphasis on peaceful you know but uh
well then then then maybe there's a real
possibility for dissolution like the
soviet union as opposed to the civil war
that's what i'm hoping for and and i'm
hoping that even if it takes a little
bit longer that we could do that and
even if it's not a hundred percent
are you actually hoping for it are you
saying
instead of violence you'd rather it be
peaceful because i'm saying any
dissolution of the u.s is a bad thing
i'm trying to look at it realistically
which is i don't know how we can come
together
as americans
when we fundamentally have so many major
disagreements
well it's not
shared values
that is keeping us together anymore it's
decadence and how comfortable we've
gotten yeah how fat and happy they're
keeping us and frankly
pop culture that they're feeding us and
no one wants to go to war because war is
awful yeah and and the people who fought
a civil war before were
made of much tougher stuff yeah
absolutely realistically it's not we're
not talking about whether it would be a
good or a bad thing it would never
happen
or maybe i'm just like operating on the
the principle that nothing ever happens
well
well yeah that optimism bias well that's
that's normalcy bias it it's it's it's
doesn't happen it's not going to happen
but uh
you know like it's what ian was saying
earlier that these people don't actually
want civil war and i agree they don't
know what civil war is right but when
you see these antifa people going around
with guns
and and shooting people like the dude in
portland got shot it doesn't matter if
you're tough it matters if you're dumb
it matters if
you know
forrest cooper was on the show last week
and he said the people who are good at
violence aren't doing it and you have to
ask yourself why that is
because because we know how awful it is
well you know the people who have
trained in war who know how to do war
are staying away from the stuff because
they don't right they know how bad it is
but the people who are engaging in it
don't know don't care
i'll tell you once it comes they'll
regret it but by then it's too late
so
i was reading this great post so let me
tell you something do you know what
bourgeois bourgeois bourgeoisie
the actual definition no do you know
anybody it just makes me think of
hoity-toity wealth wealthy rich people
wrong
middle class i think yeah it's middle
class yeah yeah is it the proletariat
that's uh working class then who's the
upper class what do they call them i
don't know
i don't know all i know is the bourgeois
bougie it means middle class
so when these when these people these
people understand is these like antifa
urban liberal types
they're the people who get purged in the
communist revolution yeah they're the
bad ones there was this is meme post
where they're like a bunch of trump q
and on rednecks are going to team up
with inner city gangs because they have
more in common than the laptop class
yeah with each other than the laptop
class
and so there's going to be these uppity
hipsters who want to eat vegan food
wondering you know what's going on and
the people who literally have nothing
are going to be like you are the people
whose wealth we will redistribute yes
and the rich people who have all their
money in panama and switzerland are
going to laugh and be like can't do
anything to me well that's a common part
of critical theory and marxism is that
the middle class is what has kept the
proletariat from rising up
and defeating and trying to trying to
overthrow the upper classes because they
see the middle class says oh that's so
attainable i want to move to that i want
to become that i bring that up though
because i think you made a good point
mary
what's holding this country together is
basically everybody's fat and happy and
doesn't want to risk their krispy kremes
in their marvel movies
i prefer not to i'd prefer to not be
shot in the street that sounds like a
horrible time well i mean like
that's the worst of it but even your
movie theater being shut down it sucked
yeah like entertainment is getting worse
our food is poison
so
if they can't even keep up the
appearance that we're comfortable and
distracted
i understand why some people's minds are
going towards civil strife at the very
least or
civil war i i i think civil war i'm
pretty sure that
lockdowns contributed to a large part of
the rioting because people were they
didn't have anything else to do
oh yeah i think i think you lock someone
in a cubicle apartment yeah this is the
crazy thing man um i think for most
conservatives who live in suburbs and in
rural areas they don't understand
that in new york city you're in a 15 by
15 box and you cannot leave
these people were effectively in
solitary confinement yeah and then all
of a sudden you see people in the
streets running around smashing stuff
you're there
the city went nuts there's nothing else
to do
well it's the one time you can go
outside yeah that's a scary thing it's
really sad the question i suppose is
you know texas talks about succeeding a
whole lot actually going to do it or
well we'll see so i think that this is
probably going to get tied up in a legal
battle and and it's going to end up just
like the supreme court and so yeah
it's going to be secession 2.0 that's
the one that you have to watch for is
how do they react after they get smacked
down and ignored by the powers that be
well i think
what uh
what we should look out for is exactly
what happened in the first civil war
texas says these other states aren't
dividing by the law they've already said
that this people need to pay attention
to this okay
look at the chronology of the civil war
the southern states said the north was
not abiding by the law because they
weren't adhering to the fugitive slave
act
not a fan of that my in my opinion the
fugitive slave act was if the slave
escapes the north has to return them but
the north certainly wasn't doing that
and i'm like okay that's a good thing
they shouldn't have but the state the
south then said if you aren't abiding by
the laws we agreed on there's no union
anyway so the federal government was not
adhering to the law and not enforcing it
so then they said okay we succeed
the supreme court can say whatever they
want if texas is outright saying this
election is illegitimate it's the gop
saying it yes
but if texas
the ag filed a lawsuit and he did the
state of texas did
and the supreme court refused to hear it
we're getting to the point where you
have a state saying
you are not abiding by the law how close
are we until texas just says we don't
care what the federal government thinks
we're not asking for for permission
hopefully we're getting close
okay but i mean it's a scary prospect
but let's think about is going to come
in what if uh
is trying to get a cup with what nuclear
submarines off the coast
i believe that the federal government
would absolutely it's not a federal it's
not a united states state at that point
this is where i'm talking about
post-secession okay if the state
department there's nothing like
post-secession see i don't think that
it'll happen that quickly i think that
what's going to happen if we have a
secession movement that really takes
takes hold is that you're going to start
to see the federal government become
more hands-off but you're still going to
see military bases and
alphabet agencies still there still
active but you're just going to start to
see the rest of the influence decline
i think if texas secedes then you're
going to have states in the union who
say we need access to x-resource now
normally we deal with texas but now
there's a border and there are new
regulations popping up and new
negotiations to be had
china then comes in and says we're going
to give you that resource 10 off
and they go you got it much more likely
to go about things that way and then
within 10 years they're completely
dependent upon china the texas industry
of oil or whatever they're producing
gets gutted and destroyed because
china's got more ability to to go like
but think about texas culture like how
likely do you think they are to be like
china come on over
they won't though but california will
california is going to be like it's way
cheaper to buy from china yes but but
then we'll see probably what we're
already seeing right now in europe which
is that people people tend to freak out
when you see another country a major
military power start to encroach on your
border and i think that the united
states even if texas completely seceded
would still keep a strong military
alliance with texas and if china started
doing anything uh particularly sketchy
i think the united states military would
lose their minds and and go to town i
look at all this stuff happening and i'm
just frustrated by how stupid
our government is yeah
because
the supreme
here's the problem it's a bunch of
cowards yeah they're all cowards the
republicans are cowards most the
democrats are cowards supreme court's a
bunch of cowards
so uh thomas and alito are probably the
only people who have any backbone to
them the only ones were willing to hear
that texas lawsuit and they didn't issue
a ruling on the merits they just said
original jurisdictions lawsuits are
within our purview we must hear them
that's it
the rest of them were like no i don't
want to be involved in this oh i'm so
scared not me right they don't want to
get swatted
yeah yeah you know if they just come out
and said we'll hear it you know we'll
hear it and then the supreme court could
have come out outright said
we reject it the states are allowed to
and hold their elections as they see fit
their vote has nothing to do with your
vote move on so the implication there is
that they didn't hear it
because they were afraid that the
country would freak out and people would
lose their minds
if they gave their honest opinions which
just means that two years later the the
confidence in the election is shattered
the american people feel like there are
there's no regis of grievances the first
amendment is trash
and now here we go second amendment's in
the gutter fourth amendments in the
gutter fifth amendments in the gutter
you ever you look at the constitution
right now and you gotta wonder what
rights are are are are being protected
at all if any
you've got major corporations who have
taken political speech
now you've got a fracturing of american
culture based on the fact that people
could not gather and communicate anymore
because no one was willing to address
that issue or should very least one
faction was suppressing the other and
you had a bunch of people in silicon
valley second amendment has been
infringed upon for the past hundred plus
years in every possible way yeah it is
clear-cut the right of the people to
keep and bear arms the third amendment
mostly mostly not being infringed but
there was one issue of uh
the eviction moratorium yeah when the
federal government said that you
couldn't evict people there were uh
landlords who said my tenant is is
active duty
that means the government is mandating i
keep an active duty service member in my
home that violates the third amendment
that was fascinating fourth amendment oh
come on
is there a fourth amendment we got stop
and frisk we got red flag laws already
in 19 states patriot act patriot act oh
come on you've got uh the metadata spawn
get the nsa
come on
look at all the x-keys score all those
things that were unveiled by edward
snowden and uh if they're if any
amendment has been crossed out so hard
it's been ripped from the paper itself
it's the fourth amendment yeah it's
toilet paper yeah fifth amendment oh
come on look at the armed armory case
there's no there's there's no right to a
a trial anymore there's no innocent
until proven guilty patriot act again
patriot act again there you go
and then if you look at the ninth and
tenth amendments taxes is right here now
there's a whole bunch of other
amendments we can talk about we can
still drink beer i guess we need we need
what gwyneth paltrow calls the conscious
uncoupling we need that from the federal
government is that what she said
when she when she split she was like
it's it's a consciousness oh yeah
yeah
that's one way to do it i guess uh luke
arkowski last week i think it was made a
interesting um illusion between the
enabling act that hitler signed that
stripped the germans of their
rights to the patriot act
and
i think that might actually be a lot
more realistic like the reichstag fire
reichstag was a burnt um hitler blamed
the communists and then immediately
seized people's rights the world trade
centers came down we immediately blamed
the muslims and osama bin laden and then
signed the patriot act i think you're
right i wish we could talk about hitler
and people would listen but that's not
they're listening no they're listening
well history doesn't repeat it rhymes as
saying goes yeah and so certainly there
are people who learn from history in
good ways and bad ways yeah you can
learn from mystery in the good way and
be like hey that was the thing that
happened it was bad and then everyone
suffered let's not do that again no it's
not other people can learn from the past
and bad ways where they're like you see
what that bad guy did that worked let's
try that you got to learn not to rush to
make legislation after a tragedy yeah no
no no no the the the politicians were
like we better rush to make legislation
after this tragedy is our only chance
yeah you look at the exploitation of a
crisis they do it every single as a just
citizen don't do it don't support
politicians that want to do it it's it's
crazy emotional power grab there's no
need to rush legislation
you've got to rush in war but you don't
need to rush the legislative that's what
career politicians do though that is
interesting right all the the crossover
between them and corporate journalists
because they got a rush to capitalize on
a crisis too everybody's like oh i got
to be the first one there it's pretty
great adam schiff came out and he was
like you know i have evidence that
donald trump was involved in january 6.
and then it was at dana bash i think she
was like what evidence well let's not
get ahead of the hearing here oh please
the dude who held up the envelope and
says i have evidence of collusion and
there was none there's like q anon it's
like you're some secret dude reporting
from a broom closet across from the
white house telling us any day now it's
going to happen right this is i don't
that's
man they're they're it's the two ends of
the same stick yep
but the issue i suppose is you don't got
queuing on people going on msnbc and cnn
or even fox news true maybe maybe i'm
sure there's some person who's got on
fox news who said something about q
whatever it's probably been a while
though right
the the you look at the prominent um
right-wing voices or moderate or
libertarian voices and they are not cute
you look at the left they're all blue
and on oh totally like 90 90 of them are
not all of them do you mind telling me
what blue anon is or means who that is
yeah you know what q anon is right yeah
blue anon is a reference to the
democrats versions of insane
conspiracies like donald trump as a
russian agent
same same thing okay but there's no
person
claiming to
stupid online forums or people believe
whatever but the blue anon people are
like any day now trump's going to get
arrested and they post memes of trump
and ham handcuffs like being walked out
and they're like it's coming it's coming
yeah they have been screaming that
donald trump is going to be arrested for
like four years now and
they're crazy conspiracy they also
believe that the 2020 election was
illegitimate that's right
isn't it fascinating everyone 2020 or
2016. oh 2016. sorry everybody thinks
every election is illegitimate it kind
of it almost makes me feel like maybe
voting isn't always the best way to
solve our problems
michael malus had a bold tweet today he
was like there's there's no upside to
accepting an election you disagree with
well
like he's right i mean right in a sense
but i kind of feel like
accepting you lose an election is
because you have a stable system of
governance and a culture in which you
agree with people right i suppose if
we've we've come to the point in the u.s
where we have no unifying culture other
than gluttony
then
dependency we've got roads and
currency and education styles and
communication
tele like i can drive to my parents
house in ohio i can you know we have a
lot of things binding us as a culture
but we have we have our culture as
fracturing is the issue yeah so internet
has really done that education let me
let me ask you guys right
uh let's say civil war happens the food
supply collapses because you know russia
and ukraine war
small town of 10 000 people what do you
think the people in that town do when
they run out of food
well it depends on the town i guess is
it like out in the middle of nowhere
they're growing their own food there's
millino or something well they're gonna
they're gonna have to go to the next
town and do what
look for food so do you think the people
in small town will work together
to go look for food some of them will do
you think the town would start rioting
amongst its uh within itself and
destroying itself as people steal food
from their neighbors
possibly i don't think so
i think a small town of ten thousand
people in the middle of nowhere where
you're gonna have people come out like
what do we do
well i don't know we have no food you're
gonna have a town hall meeting there
might be some theft the police and
people will round up that we can't allow
this we gotta figure this one out what
changes it is the internet because
you'll have like see sleeper cells on
facebook groups where they're like you
go and infiltrate your neighbor's
meeting and then we'll have an agent
there on thursday all these different
groups will come small town where people
are more likely to know each other
they're more likely to be conservative
they're more likely to go to church
together they're not going to break the
window of their neighbor's house to
steal his bread i think new york city on
the other hand their neighbors don't
know each other at all
i lived below above and across from
people i never met yeah i don't know
their names i barely knew what they
looked like that's new york city
out here we we know who the neighbors
are we only talk to them all that often
yeah but when you're out in the middle
of nowhere you're more likely to know
who your neighbors are i think
realistically in a small town setting
you're likely to see a handful of people
try to loot and write and act crazy and
unfortunately you'll see some other
people in the town put them down yeah
right they won't put up with it yeah i
think they would end that pretty quickly
and i wanted to say too i think this was
making me think that maybe part of the
reason that one in five people the
soviet union were informants by the end
was because they were living in such
close quarters because i was gonna say i
was gonna argue with tim and be like oh
no you know remember one in five people
you know people and families were
selling each other out but i was like
maybe that's because they were cramped
in like what was functionally good and
they were desperate yeah i mean
desperate to try to well not get thrown
in the gulag right but also to garner
goodwill with your superiors who have
their thumb on you
i think smaller towns
you're going to see a lot less riding
yes and you do see a lot less riding in
general for you know for any reason
in new york where the guy who lives 10
feet from the other guy doesn't know
what the other guy is oh they're going
to rob you blind it's like i'm hungry
you got beans those beans are mine yeah
it's like i think it's called the the
concept of anomie you know being
anonymous in a giant crowd because you
just can you can just blend right in
like a fish so i'm thinking about so
we've got this food shortage coming and
um let me see if i if i have this story
yeah here we go new york post says
record diesel prices could lead to food
shortages in u.s farmers warm yup
so i'm thinking about this and there was
a post from uh was it pwn all the things
a twitter account saying that like
lebanon and um yeah kazakhstan all these
other states get a majority of their
wheat from and crops from ukraine and
russia
now they're not getting that food and so
i thought what's going to happen
inside those countries
when they don't get food
i think
my opinion is lebanon will attack
another country to get food
possibly i mean i think you're also
going to see begging for for foreign aid
and that foreign aid is going to come in
and probably say for sure things will
have to get really bad before people
start going to war but the u.s is
looking at major shortages as well we
are that's what people need to
understand about the food shortage it is
not just that we don't have fertilizer
we didn't have fertilizer because of the
war in ukraine with russia that
dramatically cut our fertilizer down
they were reporting crop yields would be
down 40 percent
then you have hyperinflation already the
economy's in trouble so food's gonna be
more expensive less readily available
then what people don't understand is
that this story right here farmers need
diesel to get the crops no kidding so
now if the gas is in short supply six
bucks a gallon three times more than it
was last year and there's less food as
it was
your loaf of bread is going to be 20
bucks it's going to get expensive i will
say that with i'll give you one little
white pill though which is that these
industries some of the people who move
in these industries can make
technological advances really rapidly
the that will con that will hinge on
whether or not the federal government
administration the agencies really
federal agencies allow them to do that
and we saw them do it really rapidly
you know set aside
testing requirements for
certain types of drugs that came out
over the last couple of years i would
hope that they would do the same
when it comes to food i don't know but
it's possible so norman borlaug is the
scientist who i think he quadrupled crop
yield for like wheat and some other
crops yeah however uh i was reading
about this i could be wrong because i'm
not
going to pretend to be an agricultural
expert the crop yield increased but the
nutritional density did not
so that meant that there was a large
amount of starch available but not
enough vitamins so one of the arguments
made as to why poor people are so fat
is because in order to get the same
amount of folate or thiamine or you know
whatever b vitamins you've got to eat
four times as much heavy grains than you
used to so poor people trying to get the
nutritional value are eating massive
amounts of starch gaining fat yes so
well
i'm not i don't think i should call
myself an insider this i will tell you
that my boyfriend works in agriculture
agriculture tech and one of the things
that he talks about a lot that i've seen
is that soil health is getting improved
okay and that is a really good thing to
know and what that also means is that
they're going to become less reliant
upon antibiotics
and industrial fertilizer and things
like that so it is it is possible
but again there are a lot of regulatory
hurdles and it would take a lot of work
to get everybody implementing these
practices really rapidly but it is
technically possible and if it's
technically possible then i'm going to
be optimistic and i'm going to be like
mary and be like yay let's start
happening here yeah i'm not optimistic i
just think nothing ever happens and
everything's fake
[Laughter]
a form of optimism
in a way yeah we're gonna spin that for
you well okay
that's there's two biases there's a
normal c bias and the optimism bias yeah
normal c is what you're saying nothing
ever happens it won't happen and
optimism is
good things are going to happen it can't
be that's too bad right i skew
optimistic
uh i don't i don't know if if optimism
is the right way to look at it because
um or pessimistic it's like positive or
negative it's a thing that's happening
yeah i want to be realistic but exactly
but part of my realism is acknowledging
that i skew slightly optimistic yeah
there's the logic of it which is a
realistic thing or fantasy and then
there's the
emotional aspect of it which is optimism
or pessimism and you can be a realistic
optimist
which i seem i am i'm acknowledging that
foreign corporations are attempting to
buy us out
they're squat attempting to squander our
our wealth but i mean that doesn't mean
we can't change it
seize control well they want to make
money but so do i so competing interests
not too not too crazy of a concept i
think we can work it out to go back to
the point i was saying about the the
food and fuel stuff
is that
i think if it really got to the point
where in the u.s we're in short supply
for food and we're not a position to do
foreign aid and send food food anywhere
else these other countries
that are smaller
i don't think are as likely to
internally implode
they might yeah when there's no food and
it's due to the corruption of your
government you get a revolution when
there's no food to the foreign war the
leader can rally you and say they're
stealing our food then they can justify
invasion of a foreign country to get
food steal it from the neighbors the u.s
being so large though
i think the u.s implodes
small country sure
small state sure
big country not so much well we got
mexico
do you think we're gonna go to war with
mexico i think maybe pillage them
unfortunately like uh california and
texas there's not gonna be california
and texas agreeing like we need to you
know go to mexico and get food and
california texas texas is going to be
like california's got the food
california's got all the food california
is going to leverage that against
everybody in the country we do have a
lot of food
oh yeah it's like a third isn't it we
have a ton of food in the central valley
we don't have great water um
infrastructure so that's a real problem
colorado says uh probably not even just
colorado but arizona nevada they say we
we want food you want the water that
comes from our states without without a
federal government enforcing these
treaties what do you do
southern california exists only because
the colorado colorado river water oh
yeah and so if that gets cut off
bye-bye los angeles and san diego oh no
there you go then what they'll do is
they'll divert delta water
from the water from the delta north of
california to the south to compensate
which would turn which would it would
cause a massive influx of salt water
into the delta killing all of the farms
in the in in the bay area
and it would if only california's
government had built water reservoirs 30
years ago like everyone said they should
we we're known for a ton of horrible
policies but i promise you that we have
more horrible policies that you guys
have never heard of it's actually it's
it's a giant it's like a layer cake of
failure oh yeah man the
rolling blackouts are coming yeah uh
what are they doing they're gonna do
water rationing soon i think fuel
rationing again
second or third water rationing since
i've lived in california okay i don't
want to sound like a total idiot bimbo
but like
you're like next to the ocean right yes
so
can't you just take the salt out yeah
there are desalination plants and it's
doable it's not very cost effective yet
but that technology is also like they're
trying to improve it and i'm sure that
if we were in a real serious crunch and
the dot you know was turned off
you would see that you know propel
rapidly i'm not i'm not convinced
california can make it to be honest um
i'm not sad about it the level of
corruption and mismanagement is so
intense that i'm not convinced that in a
real crisis people would come together
to solve it okay so what if california
collapses before texas secedes
do you think that might
you think that might change people's
attitudes about secession if they see or
just politics in general in the turmoil
if they see
the i think it might exacerbate
the issues we're the 11th largest
economy in the world in california and
if that collapsed that would be well
actually you would feel that globally oh
yeah there's your there's your global
issue in you would see that like impact
the entire world there's a so in order
to make the desalination plants work you
need a you know a lot of energy yes
where is the energy going to come from i
guess all the sub city nuclear power
plants we shut down that's right what if
they use the salt from the ocean to boil
to get the heat to produce the
electricity to desalinate the ocean
water to get more salt to boil yeah they
have these giant magnetic they have
thorium nuclear reactors where they heat
up salt and melt it and then it's
thorium salts though not just so that's
something different okay molten salt the
water does they call it a mirror they
have these mirror arrays and they focus
the the light at the center tower which
is containing salt the salt melts and
then overnight it stays molten so it
produces boils water and just massive
amounts of steam power they have to
build those yeah i don't think
california is functional enough to build
those in a crisis
well no they got to start building them
now
exactly and they're not going to you
have human feces all over the streets of
several of their major cities
did you know that san francisco has a
poo patrol
oh what a what now what no they have a
food department
what do they do well okay so like you
know the fire department does right
mm-hmm like this there's a fire you call
the fire department they come up with
the fire out uh-huh san francisco has a
poo department
same thing they call like
hey there's poop on the street and then
they'll come back
i don't think they actually have sirens
or anything but they like the people
that pick up roadkill
it's job creation
there you go oh great
there's so much human feces all over the
streets of san francisco they had to
create a department they need to hit it
with lasers dude and turn into graphene
but just think about decel and
desalination which they have they have
one plant in carlsbad i think i've been
there it was really cool to watch
it they just massive tubes and they just
force at really high pressure the water
through these filters which then
purifies it and then pump out all the
brackish water back into the ocean
local environmentalists environment
environmentalists are saying
the the brackish water it's brine is it
goes down to the bottom and kills all of
the base level organisms which wipes at
the food chain straight up i'm sure it
does
so then we have to pick which is a very
uh
major dilemma for people who are very
far left and progressive what matters
more human life or ocean life
and then we have to also pick on our
energy which uh everyone hates what
matters more turning off our power and
having rolling blackouts and all that or
providing drinking water if you took
away
luxury and security from the united
states you would have no leftists
so i've said this for a really long time
and i gathered this by watching tick
tock not to the extent that you do marry
thankfully thank god i got banned yeah i
know you did yeah you can't watch
anymore no i'm just kidding they're
stealing our information but i figured
that if we got rid of free time we'd be
good we'd do fine no more free time none
of these teachers with blue hair talking
about their weird genders and confusing
people with pronouns all of that would
be gone we'd just be focused on our work
it would be fine
that's my two cents that's like the
simplest identity
because
you'd have to erase 100 years of
technological advancement anywhere near
that and free time existed in a long
time ago we had tons of free time it's
just that it's the level of
communication and the level of of hyper
tribalization that's causing the
here's what i'm saying with with uh uh
you get rid of luxury and security you
have no leftists because when people
have to think about survival that's when
they're like me and no one else and i'll
do what it takes so you're mentioning
environmentalism yeah they're going to
decide humans and they're going to
decide themselves i hope so you you're
not going to have
i mean you may have people at this point
who are like starving and on the street
crawling being like i will not eat the
food i really doubt it they're going to
be like i will eat you
and then they'll kick your door in and
they'll take your beans
you know
you're you yummy park said starvation is
like all you can think of is food when
you're working when you're starving she
came from north korea and fled the
country and said that she fled because
she was starving so she chose to go
become a sex slave in china to get out
so she had food right yeah she said that
she was like sitting there looking at
the lights and just thinking like i
wonder if there's food there people
grasshoppers like laying on the side of
the ground that have died from
starvation cannibalism i mean it's just
total total rampage yeah i think that a
lot of what we see in modern politics
particularly with feminism is due to the
fact that we are a bubble of security
yeah so if you think about evolutionary
psychology and you go bay you go way
back in time
like men were like we have to die to
protect the women because the women are
the ones who like create people yes so
you know men would
if you if you have 100 men and 100 women
and 99 men die
you your society survives because the
women can have kids but if 99 women die
you're done one woman could not sustain
a population boy that's some interesting
implications in that well yeah it's the
root it's the root of a lot of um the
gender roles if you look at it
it's look i'm not making this up this is
just like academic gender uh
evolutionary psychology
and so what happens is
gender roles emerged from that you take
a bunch of nomadic humans and they would
fortify the women because those that
didn't ceased to exist right and those
that did thrived the men would go out
and hunt big game and bring back bring
back fish or protein the women would
would you know gather and keep food and
and and protect the family and keep the
home keep the home literally and then a
bunch of the guys would die on the hunt
or in war yep but the women would
survive and have kids
so that and ends up with you know in
europe with the escalation of warfare
between nations the women are staying in
the home to be protected and the men are
going out and doing work and then you
build a society based on those ideas and
you get traditional gender roles so i'm
not saying those are good things i'm
just saying that's that's the the common
uh
human reality of our biological
conditions yeah so we end up with this
safety bubble and luxury bubble we
produce all this oil and energy and now
we have people who can
gorge themselves and not have to do any
work i mean come on let's be real
the people in new york city who work at
like buzzfeed i always bring this up
millennials oh come on washington post
this this woman who gets fired because
she's complaining about dave weigel you
know making a sexist tweet
that could not exist 200 years ago
seriously i mean maybe some of those
ideas started to exist because we had
technological advancements
but if you're like we are being
bombarded in a raiding party just stole
the last of our chickens you wouldn't be
going like you said a naughty word you'd
be like i'm dying and i need food yeah
it's it's it is first world problems
right take away the first world
all that stuff goes away i'm not saying
it's a good thing i'm just saying i
don't think the modern left could exist
in
i i kind of feel like if you took your
modern leftists
forced them to work on a farm yeah for a
couple weeks they would really change
their minds yeah unless they're like
deeply rooted in their
neuroses and then they would be like i
should be in charge of the farm and you
should serve me i mean that's kind of
what parents do with bad kids when they
send them off to wilderness survival
camp you know some of them come back
totally changed but even that is so
contrived and fake like i've been
thinking about it recently how like when
people grew up on farms and they saw
animals reproducing and giving birth and
dying
it would be impossible to have the level
of confusion about
gender and life and death that we have
right now
right if you were watching that as a
child as you grew up
you would be immune to the propaganda
that we're getting inundated with today
mccoy was on the show saying that exact
thing he was he was raised around farm
animals and had no i mean just knew from
age four he never had the birds and the
bees talk he never had to because he
always knew how sex worked was it what
sheamus i think he mentioned someone
asked him how did people
learn how to reproduce before sex ed or
something like that was it shame
assuming
somebody mentioned they had a friend who
was like how did we know about this by
watching animals what no not watching
animals like all of human existence like
i like that thing i'm going to that
person i just rewatched blue lagoon
recently
am i cancelled now because that was yes
we'll yeah we'll i won't even say why i
would be canceled for that but uh they
figured it out they figured it out they
had a baby two people stranded on an
island
since they were children it's like it's
almost like their innate biological
drives yes
and that like a dude looks at a woman
goes i would like to you know grab that
woman
yeah oh yeah
yeah yup
that's exactly it as the cartoons
dictate like how much free will do we
have as a species cause like you're
saying or you guys this keeps coming up
that like unless we're absolutely forced
to change like you're saying california
if the power goes out then you'll start
to see people like pushing this
technology if they run out of water
they're going to start desalinating how
much of this is free will like how much
are we actually in control or like
deciding to go against our instinct how
much of it is just it's free only when
we need to do it or we're going to do it
well it's it's free will but there's a
lot of people who don't exercise free
will there's long-term thinking and
short-term thinking and i think
you'll find among the
i guess culture war right whatever you
want to call it i always just say
post-liberals moderates libertarians and
conservatives a tendency towards
long-term thinking and delayed
gratification yeah and among the left
you get instant gratification and
short-term thinking high time preference
i'll give you a really good example
short-term thinking i'm seeing all of
these memes pop up it's crazy i don't
know why this meme is emergent on the
left and they're like why don't we plant
fruit trees in cities so that everyone
can just eat fruit and have to worry
about where their food comes from why
don't we just do the good things so that
the bad thing don't happen yeah do you
guys know why we don't do public fruit
trees in big cities so well there's a
couple of reasons you'll probably have
more one is the contaminants from the
air actually make the the plants
poisonous two is it takes uh sometimes
toxic yeah four four to seven years to
for a tree to bear fruit that's true and
then the other thing is when we when we
transplant fruit bearing trees into
cities the fruit rots and then you get
pests insects rats and pigeons and then
disease someone has to come and collect
the fruit and be and maintain the trees
very very
it's this remarkably childish short-term
single-layer thought yeah that i keep
seeing where they're like imagine
walking down the street and the trees
had fruit on them it's like oh and
there's no negative repercussions
nothing else happens no one's got to
care for them no one maintains them the
fruit is just there and it stays there
until you're ready to eat it that is
that is the talk of someone who's never
had a garden in their life you know why
we we grew tomatoes you know what we did
wrong we planted them all at the same
time
and you know what happens when you plant
all your tomatoes at the same time they
all ripen at the exact moment and then
it's like who wants to eat 300 tomatoes
today yeah because they go bad tomorrow
and so then someone was like tim you
need to plant them one week at a time
plant one a week later plant one then
you'll get seven the next week you get
seven and i'm like oh yeah
yeah i didn't know that but the insects
will swarm and eat them if you don't
yeah so we we throw in the chickens we
just started like there you go chickens
and then here's the best part the
chickens poop out the seeds and they
grow again oh nice circle of life yeah
yeah because the the they'd poop
wherever and then all of a sudden we
know those tomato plants were growing
and we're like oh look at that all right
well that's kind of charming it worked
out well that's that's how it's supposed
to go i mean
but you you you look at the single-layer
uh short-term thinking and that's
exactly what we've got more houses than
homeless people
what's wrong with this society we should
just put homeless people in houses and
i'm like
who's going to maintain the house who's
going to inspect the house who's going
to check the electrical wiring of the
house who is going to be paying
attention to any of the rot or termites
or any other problems in the houses
yeah you can't just put a homeless
person in the house
but they don't they don't these these
utopian thinkers typically leftists
don't think beyond that well the
prosperity we have
now that we're living off of came from
the age of reason
and
that is why i think leisure time is
valuable and is necessary for human
flourishing but then now we're
sinking into the age of the will and
anything is true if we will it
well i think that has a lot to do with
with the lack of god and i don't mean
like from an overt religious perspective
i mean it from a
people who don't believe that things
exist beyond them or
or greater than them
so the people
i feel like
there's a tendency among people who
believe i am nothing but a wet robot
nothing matters
to engage in more nihilistic thinking
like whatever feels good i'm going to do
yeah but people don't want to believe
that it's to write a blank check for
your bad behavior
it's i wouldn't necessarily say bad
behavior because that implies that
they're like a morality i think it's
self-aggrandizing and selfish behavior
carnal behavior okay
i see i see laziness and and apathy and
cowardliness also come out of that yeah
and that i think is is really
disappointing there's something about
god about knowing that the will is
outside of you at least i think it my
own will is not in my body it's a result
of the collective will of conscience or
whatever it is the earth the humans the
animals all of it but what what do you
mean you said people don't want to
believe that
they don't want to believe that they're
wet robots so there's like meat sacks
with electricity i think they do i think
some people do because i mean it removes
consequence from these actions
that's not what people truly desire well
they don't act that way it's just a
cop-out for when they don't want to
take responsibility i don't i don't
agree i think you guys are projecting
tell me more well
are you religious at all yeah i'm a
christian oh okay and you you marry as
well yeah i'm a catholic so
uh your view in your mind is is
like i think you're saying these people
certainly could not truly believe this
why would they want to feel that way
no no i mean i've i know many of these
people we had someone on the show who
was like i'm nothing but a wet robot
nothing matters yeah i think sam harris
totally believes it
but i think that a lot of the people who
adopt that worldview are not totally
bought into it and that it's just sort
of an easy way for them to not confront
personal responsibility sure sure sure i
agree with that like atheism isn't on
the rise as far as i know it's just a
religiosity that's on the rise
nobody is dogmatic
these days about
being a
an electrified meat sack like i don't
think people feel strongly and are are
animated by that belief i think they're
the exception not the rule like there's
a hand there's a handful you know the
the amazing atheist in those types yeah
i think uh
i agree with you
but i think it's be it's it's you you
don't need to be
uh a zealous atheist going door to door
and preaching the word of why there's no
god to live in a world with no moral
framework and believing your will be
done
so i i'll put it this way a tendency
among people who believe in a higher
power is the higher power has a will
over them and a tendency among people
who don't believe in higher power they
believe that their will be done yeah or
or a tendency towards which is an
interesting paradox because a lot of the
people who believe that their meat
robots don't believe in free will
that's true that's a strange it's a
strange paradox to live with yeah maybe
they're i don't know you know i was
thinking about this earlier and i'm not
uh
like i don't believe in any dogmatic
theistic religion i do believe in god i
do believe that there is something
greater and beyond us be it simulation
theory or just some purpose to the
universe
because i was thinking about you know i
was playing a video game and in the
video game you can choose to just die i
was playing spelunky you ever play
spelunky you guys know spelunky oh i
know splunky is amazing spelunky too
it's a great game and it's a roguelike
game this is a game where
you play you collect items you try to
make it to the end and if you die you
just start over and it's a procedurally
generated world that's always different
and i thought to myself in this game
that i am playing
i've come to points where i felt like
i just didn't have enough items or ropes
or i didn't have the jet pack and i'm
like meh and i just jump my gun into
spikes then the game starts over and i
try again there was no consequence to
ending my character's life right but
here in this world there there's a
massive consequence to doing it and then
i thought about that i was like that
makes me feel like there is a greater
purpose and there is something that
matters to this universe beyond me it is
not just about me and being like well
you know my life wasn't good enough i'm
going to jump on this fight and no
that'd be terrible you'd have a massive
wave of negative consequences for
everyone around you those who depend
upon depend on you and rely on you and
then i'm like so there just is easily to
me
something outside of me that matters
that
my will is not the most important will
in existence right but i feel like
people who don't see that are just like
i get what i want and that's all that
matters yep and that's why you see
people like in my opinion leah thomas
the uh the swimmer in the ncaa recently
banned i guess they're now banning leah
thomas from swimming and this is a
person who has everyone saying we don't
want you a part of our event or i
shouldn't say everybody but a lot of
people expressing that and being like
don't care i'm happy
and i'm like it's interesting
if it if if it were me and i went to a
skateboarding contest
and let's say it was a flip trick
contest for which i'm particularly good
and they were like bro we can't hang
with you we'd prefer if you didn't
compete because you're just going to win
i'd be like okay no problem i probably
wouldn't what i'm just saying if that
was if that was the instance where i was
like you're too good at this it wouldn't
be fair to everybody else i'd be like
all right i'm out i get it but imagine
being like no i'm better and i deserve
it i'm gonna come in here and everyone
has to watch me like just
aren't you like weirded out by that at
all like doesn't that make you feel bad
that's why so it's why as a libertarian
like i really stress individualism i
think it's so important
but what we also need to stress with
that is personal responsibility because
individualism just runs rampant without
any any insight or
but responsibility to other people you
know not just
like yourself right yeah that's where
you lose me with with individualism
because you don't have personal
responsibility without connection to
other people but you should
as an individual i'm i'm an individual i
control everything that i do
but i'm not
such a freak that i don't want to have
other friends and think about how my
actions
affect other people and the people that
i'm close to and they as responsible
individuals should feel the same way and
so i do believe that there is a strong
sense of connection to other human
beings through that it's through
personal responsibility and caring and
also understanding that every human
value has some sort of you know unique
intrinsic value to it and sure some
people are more valuable than others
depending on how they contribute to the
world and what they do to you
but i would say that we're all born you
know screaming and naked into this world
with still some little bit of intrinsic
unique value
i wonder where that comes from you know
because i i i was raised christian
catholic and i certainly feel like i
don't know if if there is going to be
judgment or if it's just karma but it
certainly feels like what you do matters
yes and that there's
i don't know man
because even the weight of the question
like why do we feel like what we do
matters yeah but there's a reason we
feel that way it does at least like even
if it's not true you're not particularly
religious radiant no not but i don't
follow but what about karma
i think it's definitely real i was just
studying um the phantom dna experiment
last night they bombard they take dna
they put it in a vacuum and they bombard
it with a photons and then they remove
the dna from the vacuum and the photons
stay there for like two weeks as if the
dna is still there i'm like what's a
ghost well it's probably like d it's
probably like photons that are still
orbiting uh
something that used to be there that
doesn't know it's still behaving
feeling even maybe like when you look at
these clouds of plasma and the way they
move i mean maybe they're not
intelligent but they
definitely seem to be reacting to
stimuli so so that i get you you're
you're uh alluding to some kind of
spiritual after image your energy but
your magnetic field karma
i think it exists within the magnetic
fields behavior but you but there
there's like how does how is that how is
that your program i understand if you if
you if you do something mean to someone
how does something bad happen to you
after the fact you're programming your
field or the field around you with that
behavior and then that behavior is going
to
encourage you to continue with this
programming so you're saying like your
intentions and actions emit an energy
that has a reciprocal effect back yeah i
don't know if emitted energy is exactly
the right word they seem to be spinning
the reality in a way that becomes
addictive conducive leaves the truth
right yeah that's why it's easier to do
the same thing over and over again i
noticed that in my in my baseline i feel
like it would take a long time to break
down point by point like how you see it
happening but i think the simple answer
is you believe that
there is something that happens outside
of your actions that will have like your
actions will have an impact
but i think it's the way you feel about
your actions i just think about george
bush junior war in iraq like oh well bad
karma he took us into the war he's gonna
have background but he felt fine about
it as far as i could tell so i think
it's if you feel good about doing evil
you're gonna have good karma if you feel
bad about doing good you're gonna have
bad karma that's interesting
because so i'm trying to compare that to
how i feel about
kind of something you touched on earlier
which is when you do something bad and
then you do it again
and
i don't know i don't know if i agree
with you on that because i kind of feel
like the way i've often described it is
serving serving uh organization and and
order
is
typically good and serving chaos and
destruction is typically bad but not
always but tendency towards kind of like
a yin yang kind of thing and so i kind
of view the world like
i i don't i don't know maybe like i was
saying maybe it's because i was raised
christian but i i feel
that if i wrong other people i will
regret it like so there's a badness to
it that will affect you in some way i
don't believe in hell i don't think i'm
going to be surrounded by ice or fire or
be chewed in the mouth of the devil
himself or anything like that
but i just kind of feel like
i don't know man it just feels like when
all this comes done they're going to be
like you are a dick i think everyone
knows it a good person to ask is a
soldier that killed in combat because if
you're killing for the greater good for
your country you have good karma
i hope that good karma comes to you for
doing that i don't know but in when
they're judged their soul is judged i
don't know maybe god will be like well
you evil
i think you killed therefore but i don't
think killing is but there are so many
factors that
go into evaluating an action like that
there's what the person thinks it was
just following whether or not it was
true
truly what they did
that that's their intent and then
there's the object of what they did
uh
which
some people would argue as murder but
others would argue is defending your
country yeah because you could think you
did it and have the karma and then
there's the consequence like maybe you
thought you killed someone but you
didn't
or a simulation in your mind or
something no like reverse some weird
mind a car crash happens and you think
it was your fault yeah yeah you just
mistook your action for some other
action well how does that relate to
karma if you feel guilty about something
that wasn't technically your fault you
might i just mean there are many factors
that go into
evaluating whether an action was good it
was virtuous
rap it all backward i guess what i was
trying to say is that i find a tendency
among many of these leftists is that
they don't have that fear correct they
do not fear that their actions there
will be any negative repercussions to
them that they can do what they please
and it is what it is and it doesn't
matter it's a bit paralyzing to worry
like i used to get into jainism a little
bit this religion where like you don't
even step on grass because it's too
destructive like destroy nothing leave
no trace and i'm like i can't that is
too it's too at some point you just
gotta get down with being destructive
because it's a huge part of what we are
we eat we kill and eat we destroy to
consume you know i mean i can i can tell
you about that as someone who was vegan
for 15 years um part of it is
neuroticism
i was i i abhorred violence i think i
was
um i was
i was strangely violent as a as a female
child i think i was very violent i grew
up in a very conservative home whatever
you know i was the only girl in the
neighborhood
and i had sort of a reaction to my own
violent behavior and i was very
committed to non-violence but it did get
to a point for me with crohn's disease
where i had to make a literal life and
death decision and i had to get over my
neuroses and change my diet because i
could eat nothing else
and that's
i think a lot of environmentalists and
janus and people like that have that
incredible
uh guilt associated with it and paranoia
and neuroses which is interesting
with the implications that tim raised of
basically kind of it's almost like they
don't have a conscience in these certain
respects because a lot of them also
behave in this very um compartmentalized
non-violent way towards animals and
environmentalism but it almost makes me
think maybe some of it is self-hate
hatred and self-loathing
i think it's i i want to be careful too
because i don't think it's absolute when
i say like leftist i'm not trying to say
like literally every person on the left
thinks this i just say there's a
tendency towards yeah i certainly think
um
you've got people who claim to be
conservative religious who are just
really bad people of course yeah but i
think you know typically whatever
what i'm referring to in this is not the
fringes
it's the the mainstream among the
mainstream a step like mainstream and
establishment left i question the
morality of these personalities who
don't seem to have one yes when they'll
say stop and frisk is bad red flag laws
are good
yes it's
why is stop and frisk bad well because
they they directed it at black people do
you think they're not going to do that
with red flag laws
i tweeted i'll tell you this i tweeted
this earlier i said
trans people are are
have higher suicide rates and the left
has a higher tendency towards mental
illness
red flag laws by that logic will
disproportionately affect the left yes
and um
the tennis player marina
lavatorova how do you pronounce her name
yeah something like that tweeted at me
some really nasty thing and she was just
like
you know do you do were you are you
naturally an [ __ ] or do you have to
did you have to try really hard where
did you come up with this bs statistic
the left mental illness i know where you
and pa voter fraud which is weird i
didn't tweet about and then she was like
i know where the real mental illness is
it's in this delusion and it was like
this really nasty thing and i was just
like
okay went on google typed in liberal
mental illness and then just started
screen grabbing all of the things that
came up because they do
she ended up taking the tweet down and
saying i apologize but that's the
example
high profile prominent individuals who
are angry arrogant and use their
ignorance for influence or they use
their ignora in their ignorance they
influence
not even an effort to google search it
hubris and laziness yes and that is
driving one
fact one a large portion of the
political debate well i mean you've got
the post-modern education system
telling people that truth is relative
it's objective it's whatever you embrace
so why would they go and google and
search for the truth you know we have
people like aoc saying that
that the truth isn't as important i'm
going to butcher her quote um
that it doesn't it doesn't matter you
know like it doesn't matter it's in your
heart matters if you're factually
correct it matters you're morally
correct correct there's that saying that
ignorance is bliss that it goes way back
yeah it
i think a lot of these people are living
in a state of ignorant bliss the
american dream for instance if you do
your best you can get a house with a
pick effect like yo we've been enslaving
the world with our economic opec oil
money for like 70 years it's not natural
to have this kind of luxury wake up
shatter yourself out of the out of the
ignorant
haze and look at the information it's
not pleasant but it has to happen ian
we went into the garden this is we have
a strip of wood chips yeah and uh some
some grass started to sprout and uh
nobody weeded it and it turns out it was
wheat
and then once it clearly was wheat i was
like hey look weed is growing let's
leave it
and then once it dried out like was
ready we started eating and i started
pulling it and it took like a half an
hour to get like a fourth of a cup of
you know wheat grains or whatever not an
example and i was like this is too much
work little red hen
i don't want to do this there's a russia
joke in here somewhere i can't quite
find it the the the point though is
we were laughing at how difficult it was
to by hand try and yeah pull the pull
the grains and then we have a mortar and
pestle and i was out the other day i was
mashing it i'm like this is nuts so i we
have a blender and i threw
the uh the wheat into the blender on a
low speed and it instantly pulled
everything apart and then you blow on it
and all the husk blows away yeah and i
was like that took 10 seconds the
blender thank you science but but
imagine if your entire day was dominated
by just if i'm going to live i got to do
this and you had no free time because
you're just mashing grains see how it
would be rewarding because there's
purpose in it like if there was a big
city of us and i had to be the guy that
made the bread i'm i'm [ __ ] down man
like i i i it feels rewarding to give
and to know that people are gonna
survive because of my work whatever it
is more so than like
you know hitting level 90 in skyrim
because no one although it takes many
many more hours and it's more fun some
you could even say it's not rewarding
yeah like i turn the game off and it's
not no one is eating healthy now it's a
dopamine hit but it's not
tim you say that would allow for no free
time
but i think with that repetitive action
if that were
the defining action of your life it
would end up being uh more of a
meditative practice
and people don't do that anymore because
thinking makes them sad but also you'd
be sit like ian and i were hanging out
right and we are working on this thing
together yeah there's so many
communities oh you're good at that i'd
see how you were doing it a little bit
different and then i'd start to change
mine and then not just that friendly i
would potentially i would i would be you
you'd be you'd be handing me the
wheatgrains and be mashing them and i'd
be like oh you see that bear that came
over the other day and you know it's
like you're like i'm making a very bad
hand just removing yourself from the
the object of what you're doing and you
get to build community and also if
you're doing it alone
it becomes a meditative practice i have
myself i have a friend who moved from la
out to a farm in the middle of america
he says it's the most rewarding thing
he's ever done in his life i don't know
if i'd feel that way but some people are
deeply satisfied chickens are a lot of
fun yeah i'm not big on like working to
work like running some people run just
to run and i'm not into that i like to
run to get somewhere and i like to do it
really well so if i'm making food
because people need it that's a whole
other thing yeah yeah i think we are in
the dystopian future where we have all
this luxury
and so what do you do you sit around all
day you play video games you go to the
grocery store there's your your your
spice you're flaming hot cheetos and
your mountain dew and it's just there
and it's like not that hard to get you
don't got to do that much work to live
this well it's crazy
you have people who come from south
america
central america to come to america and
come to the united states and work for
like 10 bucks an hour
at like a fast food restaurant yeah and
you ask them why and they're like i'm
gonna get 400 bucks this month this week
man i was making like 40 bucks a week
back home wow i'll be able to save up
and buy a gallon of milk and then you
know americans look at that like that's
that's crazy like you're not getting
paid enough the rest of the world looks
at it like wow
yeah all you got to do
is flip a burger and you can eat a
burger
that's crazy it is wild when i when i
worked at in restaurants when i was in
college the dishwashers who were latin
latin american always worked two
full-time jobs and they would get off of
the shift wherever i was at and go to
their other job and we were all had our
minds blown by that and they were like
well of course i work 16 hour days
why why wouldn't i work to stay alive
and send money to my family it would
just it's a completely different
paradigm we just can't even relate to it
yeah what do we have with with them with
millennials man
millennials are like the government
should give me free stuff i know
i should sit around reading harry potter
and the handmaid's tale and get money
for it a lot of them a lot of them live
in quote unquote poverty according to
them but what really is they have a
smartphone they have netflix they're in
a studio apartment and they're on
unemployment and they're on food stamps
or whatever but they're still getting
groceries from the regular grocery store
and it doesn't sound that bad i mean if
that's the baseline we've got this weird
phenomenon in the u.s and around the
world too where you can make money off
of money that you already have investing
banking so like the people that come
here to work 16 hours they don't think
it's not about i can't wait to invest
money when you have these americans that
are like i'm gonna get rich one day and
invest in my 401k and then i don't have
to work anymore well like dude you work
until the day you die my man yeah i
don't know how that 401k is doing now
yeah but let's preserve it come on man
let's preserve as much luxury that's
what i'm thinking because it's spreading
around the world people countries want
people want they want to sit in air
conditioning they want running water
they want prosperity they want fresh
showers they want good food so why don't
we have it for our but but i think it's
fair to say clean water and air
conditioning isn't necessarily luxury
climate control saves lives when the ac
goes out people die it's luxurious in a
sense i get it i don't want to downplay
that you don't need
older people do when you wave you see a
lot of older people a lot of babies die
because we're not used to living that
way either right
so there are some things where it's like
okay i think the double quarter pounder
with extra you know sauce and a super
fry and a leader of cola
maybe a little bit too much huh living
off of that
certainly i think there's a lot of
luxuries
simpler life in my opinion is is helpful
to a lot of people
but you know what i'm not necessarily
i'm not saying that luxury is bad and it
shouldn't be allowed i'm saying there's
some people who take it to a dark place
certainly there are people who work
really really hard to earn their
luxuries and are grateful and there are
many people who meditate on or prey on
the gifts they receive and there are a
lot of people who demand they get more
no matter how much they have
okay that's great yeah i don't i
wouldn't i don't think it's necessarily
a person or another person that's like
this guy's greedy that guy's not but
people can they can phase in and out of
greed due to external circumstances
being you know that's up for debate that
would take an hour to even talk about
anyway the whole point of that whole
conversation i guess was that i think
part of what the conflict is in this
country is there are people who think
they should get things from you
or from the government or like when we
had this progressive on he would and he
kept saying the government should pay
for it the government should pay for it
and i'm like that comes from the tax
payer and he's like no it doesn't dude
there's people that don't what are we
going to say it's it comes from me
there's you specifically you're the
you're the person with all the money and
the government has to come to you for
loans there's people that think that
electricity is not a luxury those people
are the problem that that state of mind
is the problem give thanks to the
running water when you have it and
last thing i'll say just pull your kids
out of public school yes
homeschool your kids
all right let's read some super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member over at timcast.com to
help support our work as a member you'll
get access to exclusive segments from
the show we're gonna have one up for you
at about 11 p.m and uh share the show
with your friends
all right
jeff c says pork fest is happening now
oh is it
yeah this week oh cool that's where all
the all the anarchists go up to new
hampshire and then fire flamethrowers
and stuff right and the libertarians and
the libertarians there will be a mises
tent oh yes
all right uh oh what's this audrey
daniel says
danielle why is mises so bigoted and
transphobic join the lppa
lppa.org help free philly don't tread on
philly.com and don't tread philly on
twitter
is mises bigoted and transphobic that's
hilarious because she's uh one of our
quote unquote token trans members she's
oh she's joking oh okay it's a joke she
got she got an award from us actually
for her oh okay for her don't tread on
philly activism she's fantastic
all right
matthew lucas says angela tell tim why
he should come to lpvw convention next
year wv wv sorry
yeah
i did get to pet a porcupine and shoot
machine guns in the snow at their state
convention it was actually incredibly
based
and they had someone clip that and they
had no infighting their convention was
delightful if they get large quantities
of uh dragon's breath 12-gauge
you know okay you ever see that
i don't know it's just like a shotgun
full of magnesium so it just like sprays
sparks i'm sure they could they have
everything
they had excellent i think they had
cannons
oh wow i'll bring out my uh my barrett
m82 and you know we'll uh
hit stuff with it
on the range safely of course oh yeah
all right
let's grab some more sherpa church
c davis as i'm afraid if we don't do
something soon there may not be anything
left to save you can't do this many
things wrong to the country on accident
i gotta wonder about that too like
that's what i was making the point about
the swattings we've dealt with and the
threats like at a certain point people
just lose confidence in law enforcement
when they're like how does this keep
happening oh yeah well i mean that's why
you got to get your own gun
oh yeah man i don't trust law
enforcement at all to do anything even
though and i know a few ex-police
officers who are libertarian and pretty
nice guys
um but they're the exception not the
rule it's just it's bureaucracy but with
guns there's a i posted this this video
i saw on reddit it was a couple i think
norwegian young men were shot multiple
times
by some random dudes and they called
their version of 9-1-1 and the lady
didn't believe him
he was like help we're dying my friend's
dying and she was like what happened and
he's like they shot me and where he's
like my shoulder my stomach and my head
and just if you were shot in the head
how are you talking huh it's like wow
they stepped i was at a shooting at a
thai restaurant in hollywood they
stepped over my waitress friend as she
was dying and walked into the restaurant
looking around just stepped right over
her body brutal man the brutal
all right
michael fernando melo says loving the
show tim cast crew the libertarian party
is in good hands with angela dave smith
and the rest of the mises caucus is dave
running for president
he hasn't announced officially that he
is running for president he just keeps
talking about what he would do if he was
officially running for president michael
malus press secretary oh man that would
be the best that might become a thing i
hope so i hope so
yeah we'll see man uh what are your
plans with the party in the short term
well we've been doing some aggressive
overhaul of our messaging
strategic planning putting together i
don't know actual plans for our
long-term and short-term future
trying to rework how we tackle ballot
access things you know i'd like to see
us do more lobbying instead of
petitioning
uh we're just basically it's a it's a
50-year startup but i'm coming in
basically like it's a startup wow it's
it's a lot of work and it is awesome and
i love it
all right
jay bobier says hey tim long time
listener do you think that the
republicans if they gained the
presidency in congress in 2024 could use
the communist control act of 1954. no
but what do you think
no
i don't think so
um cultural enforcement is more powerful
than law absolutely at this point so um
josie the redhead redheaded libertarian
often points out that the 1964 civil
rights act excludes communists from
civil rights protections did you know
that
i don't i don't believe i
picked up on that i'm like was that
amended did they change that because
it's in there i read it the 1964 civil
rights act says like this bill will not
be construed to protect those who are
communists or members of communist
organizations or something like that
when was mccarthyism over
don't know
okay probably the day he died why did he
die no i mean there were policies like
that in places the red scare interesting
yeah
joseph von wagner says be based join the
lp at lp.org oh well there you go
ryan's reaction says i was here before
the civil war hi mom
well all right
all right
shark bite biz says special shout out
special shout out to angela from david
strasser angela will be shark by uh
angela will be shark bite biz season 4
finale next monday on youtube and rumble
keep up the good work angela rock on we
need more people like you yeah he's
really awesome dude you're going on
what is it i'm going on his podcast next
week oh cool we discuss it's less
libertarian politics and more about
policy and industry and how government
you know
ruins those things for us all
all right travis bost says the lp of the
eastern panhandle would love a shout out
or even a visit meeting this wednesday
at the ladder house in martinsburg and
also our lpep convention on 7 16
this wednesday unfortunately for me i
work 16 hour days and then this weekend
we're going to new york for the festival
of mines festivals festivals of mines
festival.mines.com that's it yeah yeah
hope to see yeah mine's a festival of
ideas festival ideas there you go check
it out festival festival ideas in new
york city is going to be epic tulsi
gabbard james o'keefe me it's going to
be a lot of fun yeah yeah was it
festival.mines.com
uh we got a whole bunch of people saying
dave smith 2024. jake moore says hey
angela mcardle you the real mvp can't
wait to see you what see what our party
will become under your leadership also
dave smith 2024. it's happening
it is happening it's happening
unofficially
unofficially because no exploratory
committee has been launched yet to my
knowledge so it is unofficially
happening
well all right all right i look forward
to it that'll be fun
and then as soon as we pulled up the um
then we have a bunch of super chats
because as soon as we pulled up the
one uh display on the screen it shut the
mics off so there's a bunch of people
saying no audio no of course thanks for
the super chats telling us there was no
audio all right dark horizon says it's
really funny to see everyone's faces
react to what tim is saying when nobody
on stream can hear him i wonder what
that was like it's a secret yeah well we
can watch it i don't know yeah it's
going to be two minutes i think of dead
air so maybe
i don't think we can do anything about
that i'll see what i can do i don't
think so i can fix it i don't i don't
think so well we started reading it
again so i'm probably for the podcast
i'm just gonna go and take it out for
the podcast version i don't think
youtube allows you to trim stuff they do
it takes a really really long time to
process a podcast on the live stream
they allowed it before really because i
know we had that problem before where
they were like we couldn't take it out
of the live stream version yeah we only
though we had to trim something one time
and we made it happen it just took hours
took forever oh yeah it takes like three
days
michael heiss says tim would you support
a dave smith candidacy for president
with michael mouse as press secretary
yes 100
absolutely
yeah
it's the the the challenge here is
always the the the practical versus the
the realistic versus the idealistic yeah
yeah
if trump was running against some awful
democrat i'm like trump's not that bad
however
um if dave smith's running then
i would like to see a dave smith
presidency with a michael mouse press
secretary so i would like to see it i
would i would support that to a great
deal i want
i want to be promoting that
from the libertarian party i want you to
go to lp.org and you just see that
everywhere i just want that that's going
to be so good i want to see michael
mello sitting down with like
i don't know
meet the press yes
yes he's going to be selling i want to
see him on good morning america yeah joy
behar on the view that's where he
belongs
what are they gonna do
they're like they have to it's the lp
it's like big enough to where they have
to cover it they will cover it dude dave
smith's the only one talking about yemen
man and what a what a horrific atrocity
is passively being caused there by the
americans we are about to launch an
awareness campaign through the national
libertarian party on on yemen we're also
going to be doing something on inflation
in bitcoin but yemen is coming up this
week
gone fall says i do not want a civil war
but these democrats have been
suppressing us our opinions our thoughts
they hate us they want us gone they do
not share our american culture and
morals any longer people tend to rebel
but they're not american dude don't get
surprised
this is what's funny when like you hear
them say all the time like our democracy
is in danger and i'm like no they mean
it they do they mean their democracy not
our constitutional right
they've been building their democracy we
live in a constitutional republic and
the democracy is threatening our
constitutional republic and so we are
like that's bad and their democracy is
losing and so they're like our democracy
democracy is
two wolves and a sheep voting on who's
for dinner i hate democracy you could
you can quote me on that everyone
libertarian party not a fan of democracy
a republic is a well-armed sheep
contesting the vote that's right
all right
joseph von wager says uh live in pa be
based and join the libertarian party of
pennsylvania now at lppa.org look at all
these ads for the libertarian party
popping up throughout this the
pennsylvania party is incredibly based
yeah they are really good love them
all right joshua clark says the most
basic question is not what is best but
who should decide what is best dr sowell
libertarians believe you should decide
what's best for your life join us if you
believe in all freedom for all people
lp.org
everybody just shout out lp.org i i
thought we were going to get a lot more
shout outs for the mises caucus rude
corey tallman says the republicans sold
you out with red flag laws the democrats
think the economy is doing great the
liberty libertarian party is the only
party that cares about freedom and then
join the lp.org and join the mises
caucus a lot of super chats okay there
you go well i will i will tell you that
that is true and unfortunately even ron
desantis has not got a good track record
on red flag laws so that is yeah
something i one thousand percent opposed
19 states already have it
you've got a bunch of republicans
signing on for gun control
the establishment is the establishment
the unit party is the unit party they're
the the trumpians may have got in
and made some big changes but they
resisted they sabotaged trump in a lot
of ways he made that mistake man
all right let's let's jump down and grab
a bunch of super chats
tim mcdonough says ian i'm glad you're
back i wanted to recommend a book called
beautiful outlaw by john eldridge it
really changed my view on religion it
gave me permission to be a real man and
a christian jesus was a prankster and a
gangster keep a pushing team oh
interesting nice
all right
waffle sensei says we were victorious in
the world war because we were half a
globe away and didn't join the war until
the very end
now the one target every other world
power is watching to fall is america we
need to be we need to all be smarter
yeah definitely man
jameson says did you see joe falling off
his bike nice to see him finally
learning leaning right in something
how's it going
yeah he fell because he was where he had
clips on the pedals
and so
when he took his left foot out he
started to lean to his right take his
right foot out but he got caught in the
clip
forward okay because it was way it was
weird to watch yeah he stopped and then
he just his foot got stuck in the jumper
oh man yeah did anyone rush to catch him
no they just watched it happen
it was like the meme just come to life
the bike meme
the bike meme come to life
oh man
mr obvious says people keep saying that
if the union shatters it will cause a
civil war but if the union doesn't
shatter it will also
it will also cause a civil war i fear
that we cannot coexist at this point
something has to give
good observation so
over the past 12 years or 14 or 15 years
the country was split into a long time
ago and they're getting so far away from
each other there's no bringing it back
together i'd rather take the risk and
secede try to do it as peacefully as
possible
you don't know till you try maybe maybe
negotiations to some degree i mean what
about just like heavy federalism in the
states rights and all that stuff i would
take it i would anything in that
direction i'd take it
yeah
i fear that uh it's not the direction no
there's no point in fighting ourselves
inward it's multinational corp it's
these mega corps that are trying to buy
the world that is the issue to focus on
remember settle for biden remember that
being a thing i'd settle for federalism
kane iv says tim's ad runs are hilarious
elon has a dispute with texas elon has a
dispute with texas lawyers tim you know
where i like to get my meet
so we we have ads that appear in the
podcast and some people point out that
there's like some it just jumps to the
ad sometimes so like it you know it'll
be funny me saying something like
there's a major lawsuit happening right
now with elon musk and i purchased my
meet from mointbox.com
free shout out yeah free shout out guys
uh clayton pagiunis said i'm a mises
caucus member and the libertarian
candidate for congress in njo7 i decided
to be the change i want to see check out
clayton4congress.com
there you go i would love to see some
libertarians win congressional seats
so we're going to make it happen we're
working on that but the way that it's
got to really play out is we've got to
make that a long-term goal we've got to
focus on winning local elections right
now you still got to run people at the
national level because that that's how
you get the name recognition but the the
bulk of our attention needs to be on
localization and grassroots so that we
can stack political capital gain
experience and then start moving up is
there any value to politicians that are
already in office switching their party
yeah and one of the things that i'd like
to do is try to convince people to
switch on their last term whether
they're terming themselves out or
they're moving on to something else like
if you could switch their last six
months to libertarian i think that would
be really good for us
all right david robinson says those
saying civil war will never happen have
normalcy bias
those who think it will have quote when
will something interesting happen by us
when are you guys having justin amash on
i was very critical of him uh several
years ago but i'm definitely interesting
i'm definitely interested in having him
on to to to talk about all the stuff
because i don't even remember what the
issues were several years ago was
something about him coming out and just
impeding trump and a bunch of stuff like
that
really good insight on being a
congressman he can provide that a little
bit of
the tds right there yeah but yeah that
was that was basically it yeah still
worth the confidence i i think the issue
was it's been a long time that i didn't
feel it was genuine that it was just
like tds now i'm gonna be a libertarian
because and i'm like oh man i don't know
about that but i'm you know like i was
critical of thomas massey and he tried
to be right so i'll eat that one and
then we had him on the show and he was
fantastic yeah
so you know it is what it is
all right
what do we got
prince namor says jaws oh hey jaws is 47
years old today happy birthday jazz oh
happy birthday jess happy birthday jaws
happy birthday to my friend gary sun
whose name i can't remember it's his
birthday
clint torres says mary so miss watching
y'all live but i'm out of the country on
business trying to keep up but it's not
the same happy to see you here though
love everything tim cast oh i appreciate
it he makes it rain on pop culture
christmas
oh does he yeah
so uh for those that don't know
on pop culture crisis it's live what
monday through friday at 3 p.m yeah 3
p.m eastern time and noon pacific time
if you're on angela's side of the
country if you super chat
money guns fire
distracting
ooh and then after like 100 bucks or
something the sirens go off and then it
makes it rain and it's like
different surprises
party a crisis party i'm gonna have fun
over there i'm gonna tell all the
libertarians to start super chatting
that they're gonna love that [ __ ]
go subscribe to pop culture crisis
i was on it last week was it last was a
week before last we talked about ezra
klein as well as that's where miller is
a different guy a different guy i don't
know a lot of ezra is better than ezra
yeah dude that story was crazier ezra
miller this story is insane yeah watch
the show but we talked about it today
actually it never ends my gosh
but like uh
ian got sprayed with money to win his
coffee yeah one of the bills he flew
through the air and then went right in
so there's like a meter that fills up
and once it once it hits it's like yeah
we've got a crisis meter we're just
chickens we were talking about it and
people were like what if tim cast
ireland did something and i was like
we're like a serious prime time right
sure it'd be like really weird if we
were spraying money guns at each other
although we have before yeah it's
definitely lighter material than what
you get on irl so
you know if if talking about pop culture
also like makes you feel like you're
losing your mind a little bit then i
think it's some place that you can feel
like you're normal yeah it makes us go
crazy too it does i'm someone that
completely avoids it but being able to
talk about people that know what they're
talking about is really invigorating i
just want a money gun i'm really into
this oh yeah they're cheating
all right 2076 says watching live at
porkfest looking forward to tomorrow 3
p.m we have a panel on secession live
free and thrive
nplpnh was the first state to vote on
secession article 10 at new hampshire
constitution
there you go yeah new hampshire is doing
incredible work i got the the free state
project and the libertarian party used
to be at odds really well i mean i've
i've disclosed a little bit that their
wokism had infiltrated the lp and so as
that has been on its way out uh
now the libertarian party and free state
project are best friends again as they
should be cool
all right nightmare ghostify says tim i
moved to austin texas this year from
another texas city companies are moving
people from cali and the cult types are
coming with them that's city urban
liberal types
they they still think blue no matter who
no questioning dem failures
oof
yeah so when people were like go to
texas i was like i don't know about that
oh well it could end up flipping blue i
really hope not because that is
imagine being in texas and it flips blue
and you're like i built a business here
and moved from california
i would have another
world view imploding but the rio grande
valley man looking at uh
what's happening with the hispanic
community voting republican i think it's
actually probably pulling the other
direction yeah plus with uh people you
know like like joe rogan or michael
malus moving down there
i think it's it's going to be red i'm
moving down there in a couple months
there you go
what's the libertarian the libertarian
party is yellow right yeah gold gold
there you go gold and black yep that's
amazing
yeah oh yeah so if we're in a simulation
which we might be those are my high
school colors i think there's something
good my problem with libertarianism is
that the freedom idea of freedom i feel
like we've created kind of a prison that
we live within that protects us to be
free within the prison and without the
external prison force of the u.s
military we're not we might think we're
free but if the bombs start dropping no
one will will protect us cut those
prison bars in
come over to freedom um
i
i i totally understand people's concerns
about military might and foreign empires
i don't think that military defense
would collapse if we were more
libertarian i think we would just bring
our troops home so that we wouldn't have
entangling alliances all over the world
and we would probably have a much more
robust defense system what about the
problem when if you're fortified and
entrenched in one area that everyone
knows where you are they can organize
around you and coordinate and attack
well we still have nuclear power
we don't no one wants to see nuclear
world war that would be horrible
yep an armed society is a polite society
and that that means goes the same
globally oh yeah
synthetic greed says hey tim i was
wondering if the event you are going to
on the 25th will have any sort of
recording or vod available love you guys
and keep up the great work uh was it
festival.mines.com that's it there are
streaming tickets i believe yeah you can
watch it live actually i believe yeah
that'll be fun
you all should come out if you can in
new york because we're going to be in
new york city and it's a it's a big
theater it's going to be massive this is
this is crazy i can't believe it it's at
the pumpkin yeah it's the beacon and
it's a it's it's not just it's a mix of
like left and right you know it's like
there's actually a free ticket request
form for people that are in new york
city or close to the area on uh
it's at festival.minds.com i mean we are
packing this place so
get a ticket i know times have been hard
for a lot of people financially which is
like we uh bill had booked the event
before covet like a year before covet
and then covet was like hello economy
and so now people are like yeah i don't
know 75 bucks is a lot to go to new york
city to get a hotel but their free
ticket request form too so check out
those free ticket request form at
festival.mines.com all right
minami snowen says this is civil war
collapse the death of god loss of faith
in man culture god etc and many things
recurring at once setting the stage for
what's to come my philosophy website
beza bazar.com
yeah you know
looking at the food crisis the fuel
crisis the ukraine russia war and civil
war i'm like everything's sort of
happening all at once it's it's
everything everywhere all at once i
worry about that movie
no i that movie i heard bad things about
it i loved it it was it was i thought it
was good but anyway it's like all of
this is happening all the same time and
it feels like the end result is going to
be
from the ashes of the old we will build
a new yeah i worry about a rise in
fervent nationalism because that is not
going to be a long-term solution
because that is not good for a private
industry either and it's not good for
individual rights yeah that's what
happened in hitler's germany nationalist
psychopathy took over they came in and
took over there was all the
quote-unquote degeneracy and you know
people not having jobs and civil unrest
discontent
started blaming
certain people not a good scene david c
cronk senior says i love it tim says
where do you get the energy ian
basically replies just build the
perpetual motion machine love you guys
hey fusion's not perpetual emotion your
life will really extract the salt from
the water to create the energy to
extract the salt from the water well in
addition to sunlight which is bouncing
off the uh the mirrors that's true
that's true
all right ari jacobson says
i
a-u-e-d lorenz new york times for oh
sued it's the typo i sued lorenz new
york times for defamation i'm a woman
not rich not famous not white not guilty
of the crimes taylor published if my
case is dismissed msm darlings keep
lying with impunity truth matters hold
them accountable tim
so that's at little miss jacob i'm gonna
write that down i wanna take a look at
that yeah good luck with your lawsuit
i am writing
right hang
i'll write that down and i'll take a
look little little miss jacob is it on
twitter i'm assuming
she defamed you
interesting
oh there there's the correction i sued
taylor lorenz new york times for
defamation i would love to hear about
that looking that up right now
all right the happy holistic says tim i
have a new anti-woke sitcom script for
you or daily wire called the whites
script for pilot is available on amazon
uh wrecked by your former guest dave uh
riaboy contact info is on amazon page i
love that we have a we have a joke i'm
gonna spoil it but we were talking with
jamie kilstein who's gonna be helping
put together the jokes for the vlog and
he's his bid is kind of like the only
place that would hire him because he's
like a progressive is tim cast because
he got cancelled and then i said well
it's either this or the daily wire so
that's like a running joke is the only
place you can get hired at if you're
canceled is like here at the daily wire
gina chrono's back i hope you guys
checked out that movie
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna say this because
i love the daily wire guys i have had a
hard time trying to watch it i've been
trying so hard to watch their movies i
haven't seen them yet i need to they
gotta get the smart tv apps up oh
yeah oh you're right because they would
get way more viewership and membership
if they had sony and lg because we have
sony tv and lg tv and i pull up the apps
and i can't get the daily wires so we
tried doing you know casting from the
phone and stuff and i'm like man so it's
only on their website or their app so
it's like apple roku uh okay um because
we've been wanting to review terror on
the prairie you can get it on roku yeah
okay you have to have a membership to
the site which we use so we can use that
streaming service yes it's just that i
have an lg tv so i've got all of the
apps on it like youtube tv and stuff but
i can't get daily wire so i i told this
to jeremy i was like get your tv apps
man because like we will watch all of
this stuff we'll turn on ben shapiro and
everything too
or just you know because i can't watch
the movies
but it's it's just
figured out
but you know what man they're coming up
and i'm really excited to see it super
excited for tara on the prairie that's
awesome looking side i'm looking forward
to watching it
all right
choice music says ian i believe we
actually have what is what is called
willful destiny yes we have will yet
outside influences whether you're
religious or secular guide our choices
such as god and pharaoh and exodus god
hardened his heart or survival and or
cowardice
that's for sure like we have we're bound
by outside forces that we need to eat to
survive but we have free will to not eat
there are people that just choose not to
and they die so you do have free will
even though there are external forces
i like it
a green clover says ian to the response
of libertarians that live far away and
rohan will answer
there you go
that's that's trust that's faith in a
system
well it's faith and trust in other
individuals that you've developed
relationships with
very important
matt says huge thanks to angela for
motivating us in nebraska join us in
supporting her leadership lp.org and
lpne.org
based me caucus
right on
hearing good things it's crazy i mean
it's been like kind of rapid rise for
the mises caucus right well it's taken
about five years so it feels kind of
rapid
i know right well it started in uh the
summer of 2017. i got involved
like within a couple months basically as
soon as i heard about it i was already
active in the party by the way and i'd
already run for congress you know but i
was like well this is really what i care
about this is this is the thing this is
what it's supposed to look like and i
said you know in 2018 i was like that
was kind of rough we didn't win at
convention maybe in four years i'll run
for chair i work really hard study do
everything i can here you are
what is it about the mises caucus that
stands out
we want to make the libertarian party
more welcoming to libertarians there is
a much larger liberty movement and the
libertarian party has
historically in the last 20 years
especially rejected it and gone more
centrist moderate in over the last five
years like very woke
and begging for mainstream
remember uh who was the who was the
candidate last time
the presidential candidate
oh gary johnson or joe joe jorgensen joe
jorgensen and she said we you know what
did you say it's not enough to be not
racist what we must we must be actively
anticipating and i just thought it was
funny that the libertarian party telling
us what we must do
it was it was
painful i love joe she's a sweet lady uh
that was i would say that she got some
very bad uh messaging
campaign advice
here's a very important one we'll get
one more in here free men die free say
hey angela persuade tim for an episode
with ron paul tim's show is a great
platform to spread the same message we
all learned ron's time is ticking uh ron
has a dr paul has an open invite to come
on the show whenever he wants we are big
fans of ron paul
uh we had a christmas tree this is
almost two and a half years ago and luke
rutkowski put a picture of ron paul on
top and he said i couldn't decide
between a star or an angel so i chose
both
nice and then afterwards he just stuck
the picture of ron paul on one of the
doors in the house and it's there right
now ever since but we're big fans so i
bet scott horton or daniel mcadams could
probably arrange that yeah i will fly
there tomorrow if that's what it takes
well
in texas wherever yeah wherever he's in
texas
he's in texas i think it's a lake forest
we would have to drive out the yeah it'd
be great mobile studios after next or
something i mean it is time well i will
i will reach out and connect you if
you're not already connected i think
you've had scott horton on yeah yeah we
have right yeah yeah i skated with him
i'm pretty sure he did yeah that was
cool i did a kickflip pivot in the mini
ramp
awesome it was like midnight and i was
like i can't say i'm tired he's like you
have to when i was like oh scott's
always he goes 100 miles an hour yeah
i'm a fomo now so for everybody watching
i can't skateboard even though i like to
skateboard because i'm pregnant
and everybody will be like
would ron be able to travel out here or
possibly that would be amazing he
traveled to our to our national
convention that's right that's right yes
yeah we covered that uh timkes.com yeah
yeah he was great too the person you
sent all right yeah chris chris carr if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com because we're gonna record
that
only segment uh it'll be up for you by
11 p.m and we're talking about cultural
issues and it'll probably it'll be
uncensored it'll be not family friendly
so just so you know and um
if you want us if you want to follow us
we're on instagram at timcast irl
basically everywhere at 10cast.org you
can follow me everywhere at timcast
angela you want to shout anything out
yeah if you want to join the libertarian
party i think you've heard it about 10
million times by now it's lp.org if you
want to get active in your state party
which is also really important the best
way to do that is to go to
lpmiesiscaucus.com
they will get you connected with whoever
you need to get connected with all 50
states
right on
mayor you want to show anything out yeah
i'm going to repeat myself too go over
to pop culture crisis subscribe
uh we're also on spotify uh
pandora everywhere you listen to
podcasts
come join us it's a lot more fun than
what we do over here on irl where we
talk about uh
uh we talk about celebrities being
insane and movies and tv shows we do
reviews
um so come join us over there and also
if you want to follow me
i'm on instagram and wechat at closer
kitty
great to see you guys thanks for coming
um i want to shout out luke rudkowski
who may or may not be still be in the
chat he's at pork fest this week ah
what's up homie and also uh special tech
tidbit i just found out f saw evidence
that the sun may not actually be
super hot gas but actually metallic
hydrogen that's hexagonally latticed
just like graphene
and boraphine this hexagonal line you're
so crazy perpetual motion there's a
video called the sun is not a gaseous
plasma the lmh solar model check it out
bye
well i have nothing so smart to add but
thank you guys for tuning in this
evening with my lady versions of a
libertarian catholic great conversation
ladies thank you for coming mary's a
little bit nervous before she came on
she did great we do have a great time
over on pop culture crisis i'm on every
wednesday and i think this wednesday i'm
on with andy gonna be super fun looking
forward to that you guys can find me on
twitter at minds.com that's our patriots
as well as sourpatchlist.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you